hi I'm Christopher Hine today we're
going to talk about my seventh form so
the seventh form that I do which is
analogous to cyto sensei's fifth form so
very similar to his fifth form um I put
six and seven together because they have
the same intro and that's also true for
cyto senses they have the same beginning
piece um and so when I do it you see two
different answers that could happen from
that same situation uh so I'm G get Josh
over here we're going to go work
Josh
all right so let's talk about my seventh
form um which is analogous to cyto
sensei's fifth form uh I'm going to show
you the way that I learned this form and
then I'm going to show you the slight
changes that I think maybe should happen
although I still mostly Do It um this
way I'm going to show you right now okay
so I teach it with the exact same
beginning as the previous form so my
seventh form my sixth form have the
exact identical beginning also Al so do
cyto sensei's second form and his fifth
form right so and that basic idea is
this that I'm in a panic State boom and
I pop this to the side and then I
immediately thrust back in at Josh now
the way he dealt with it in the last
form was to um go by me with like an UK
Nash style action here boom he slides in
and then we're in the close- range
position he goes for the lake right
another way that you could interpret
this form that isn't this way also is
just like first form right so when we do
this he could just back up and juch back
uh yeah that's this form yeah there we
go boom so he can just jod and guch back
right so this is just like first form so
I'm here and I fire for him and he gets
back okay now we already learned
basically all those lessons in first
form so we don't need to repeat that
here so are there any further ideas and
I believe yes this next one is a further
idea he could just jump back in a
relatively the same position right so
when I fire in he just jumps back right
so that's always he's looking for us
just to jump back out of the way he's
not trying to strike me or anything else
so we're not seeing that he's just
getting out of the way okay now from
this situation where he's out of the way
for another thrust right what would I do
well we learn in first form that I would
jodon to get him right so this is what
I'm going to do boom I'm G to track him
down with the Jordan Huch so what he
does is he throws a katate gang so as we
come up here boom he's popping me with
the
katang however in the form I see it
before gets that far so he does that I
duck right underneath and I protect my
head coming here right and so the reason
I'm getting low is I'm defending
absolutely everything in one action
right so defending my legs my head and
everything in one action because I get
out of the way so even if he changed his
angle here to hit me boom I'm defended
against this right and that's all the
way down so I'm in a really good
position for everything okay where you
should be opening your hand is this one
because more likely he's going to try
and hit your head here in this less
likely he's going to try to hit this
hand however if I did see him go low I
could change that at a moment moment's
notice right but but your normal
position should be this all you're doing
is turning the stick over so look I was
already doing that anyways I'm coming
over like this and all I do is change it
as I drop down to one knee okay now from
this he's going to let it swing through
just like a normal Kat get Gish and then
his idea is to smash me on top of the
head Bonk when he does that I bring my
hands over first like this and then I
try and make this glance off as much as
I can coming here and then boom I'm set
up for a really nice thrust there okay
so so basically the way I learned this
and let's switch roll go here real quick
for this right okay so I come in Josh
he's going to knock that away then he
thrusts in at me and the way I learned
it was to pull back like this and then
as Josh comes in I swing through here
like this to him and then I come down to
smash him he pushes that to the side and
then he thrusts me here okay I think
it's good to understand what's happening
in that moment of the katate Gish so in
cyto sensei's work when we see kenish
we're always seeing it from this
position I think this is really easy way
to teach new people how to do this so
they get less confused however what you
really should understand is that that
action is in subet right so the way that
I teach my partner forms and we'll see
those eventually is that when we get
here this action is a sliding action
just a secondary sliding action and that
makes the action much more deceptive
right so meaning here in this when uh
actually I want to do the other rule
sorry when Josh comes in for me and I
just hop back right like this I'm
setting up a subet now what could happen
here is Josh could come with a jodon
guch and he could get me here if I tried
to subet him right but I'm going to make
way more link so if Josh goes it is
exactly the same link you can see here
I'm still going to clip and don't don't
outspeed me so you can see I'm going to
clip him so even though he pushed back
with this attack if he goes back I'll
still get him because I'm going
one-handed right so one-handed gives me
more length than two-handed will right
so so that's the advantage of using this
action even if he was going to pull back
from a ski he could still do that so if
we used first form answer for this right
so so in first form answer basically
sorry we gota be this real so first form
answer would be this I come in Josh pops
it to the side and I hop back and now
I'm expecting Josh to cover the distance
with Jan g h and I have pop him here now
if Josh knows first form answers coming
he can scoop back slightly beyond that
okay but if he does the same thing with
this what's going to happen is this I'm
still going to tag him still going to
tag him so I get more reach so I'm
actually taking care of both situations
here where if I just went back to the
other one I would only take care of one
situation so uh it's a better strategic
Advantage for me right and it's another
addition to how this ranging situations
work so this is a real nice special
little bit in in a form here I think
that shows you ah here's another idea
that could come and that's that
onehanded extends further right so with
this oneand extension I can get even
further than he can in kinami right so
skii is pretty limited k Kam gives you a
little more reach but katate stuff gives
you way more reach and so here's a
caveat where that might play out so
maybe that was actually overexplained
for some things but but yeah there
there's a bunch of information for you
so I'm Christopher Hines Joshua thi
behind that camera right there is Maya
solono McDaniel we'll see you in a
future video